and the powers of the scottish
parliament that we are proposing
are in 12 different areas where we
believe it can be strengthened
in land use so that we have more control
over the land of scotland reforming the
crown estates commission in transport so
we have the option if we want to
that there will be a non-profit free
railway company non-profit-making
railway company running scotland
on jobs the work program devolves so
that we can get our young unemployed
into work more effectively by decisions
here
skills training apprenticeships so that
we can actually
do what should be done already and that
is to give young people the chances they
are not getting to have decent
apprenticeships and then on the
infrastructure
to be able to build better
social and economic fabric
for the whole of scotland by borrowing
and by investment powers to invest in
the future
powers over elections and attendance
alliance we know the problems we need to
integrate health and social care
so we will have powers over attendance
allowance within the scottish parliament
housing benefit
there never again could be a bedroom tax
imposed by westminster on scotland
because we will give the power to set
housing benefit to the labour people and
everybody else who's in the scottish
parliament
these are big changes that we are
proposing